I think I am more excited for this
Dragon Ball super review than I have
been for any of the other ones I've made
in the past and it has a lot to do with
the content of what I'll be covering in
this ARC today but also in part due to
this quote from the artist behind Dragon
Ball super toyotaro following the
release of Dragon Ball super volume 18.
in that he said thanks to all of you we
made it to volume 18. going by mere
volume count alone we made it to the
same number as Dr slump it was at this
point that Toriyama Sensei started
Dragon Ball meaning that I am also
finally at the starting line I can't use
lack of experience as an excuse anymore
I will do my best that is an impressive
statement of humility and a
demonstration of his own determination
to get better and I honestly respect
that it's been about two years since I
last reviewed a story from Dragon Ball
super and with this latest one the
granola Arc it highlights something I
love about modern Dragon Ball perhaps
more than any other Arc that's come
before it I've tried to remain as object
active as I can in this review and while
I do have my criticisms of some creative
choices made in this latest Arc I must
say that the themes explored are
interesting and it boasts one of if not
the best First Act to an arc I've yet
seen produced by modern Dragon Ball I
hope you're all sitting comfortably
because we're about to dive back into
the expressive impressive and wonderful
world of Dragon Ball I'm totally not
Mark and this is my review for the
granola Arc
tonight
never never
[Music]
before we go any further I want to take
a moment to talk to you guys about vesi
they're a sneaker company who reached
out to me to partner for this video and
I've been so impressed with their
products as I'm sure you guys know at
this point I've been hugely into running
lately having tackled two marathons this
year and the prep for that involves a
lot of training no matter the weather
and if you've seen Ireland you know it's
not exactly all sunny skies what makes
vessi so distinct from their other
brands is that they're 100 waterproof I
can literally dip my foot into a puddle
and my sock is still totally dry now you
think achieving this would come at a
cost of comfort and weight but they're
actually insanely light and breathable
thanks to something called dimatex it's
black magic really it keeps you nice and
warm in the cold but super cool in the
heat definitely a big bonus to someone
who trains all year round although they
do offer more Sports oriented looks I
think the fact the ones I own don't
immediately look like the kind of shoe
you'd run in play a big part into why I
love them it's not always ideal to have
to abandon your comfy shoes for not
being fit for the occasion so the fact
that these look good enough to wear on a
night out is a huge Plus for me
conquering Irish puddles and looking
good while doing so what's not for love
right on a serious note though vessi
have quickly become my go-to shoes so if
you're looking for some seriously
versatile offerings with the added bonus
of it being waterproof head over to
vesi.com and use the code on screen for
25 off each pair thanks again to vesi
for sponsoring today's video
you know what's weird having just
recently read through like 500 chapters
of bleach to hop on for a review of a
Dragon Ball super Arc that's like 20
chapters long was a really weird
experience it was like I had been away
training in the gravity chamber and now
suddenly my body feels normal again
having ran from December of 2020 to
August of 2022 the granola Arc is the
first Arc of Dragon Ball super that I
decided to read in chunks rather than
month to month and honestly I think it
works better that way waiting the full
month between chapters only for it to be
a continuation of an already commenced
fight can get tiring and I'm gonna be
honest with the amount of reading I have
to do week to week for other stories it
didn't give me enough with any given
month often times to keep my attention
so instead of that I decided to wait a
few months read a bunch and progress
that way so the first time I finished
reading this manga happened to be this
week right before writing this video and
man
some stuff happens in this Arc last time
we touched base in a super review I was
singing the raises of the moral Arc and
one of the reasons I was so impressed
with that Arc was largely due to what it
stood not only to offer itself but
additionally what it offered to
everything that came afterwards this Arc
gets to explore the consequences and
ramifications of the previous in ways I
as a long time reader thoroughly enjoyed
so let's take a look at the First Act of
the story that I loved so much the
introduction the introduction of any
story is largely the section that's used
to establish what makes the Arctic
bringing to the Forefront the goals
themes and calls to action for the main
players and boy does it do just that
chapter 67 largely contends with the
conclusion and aftermath of the moral
Arc Goku and the gang getting recognized
for their efforts by the galactic Patrol
and interestingly 7-3 being taken away
by a minion of someone called Master
goichi right before Jaco and the
galactic Patrol could confirm 7-3's
death and it's in this ship we meet the
titular character of The Ark granola
he's a bounty hunter and armed with his
AI companion oatmeal together they
infiltrate Master goichi's ship and
retrieve 7-3 for delivery to their own
employer as first glimpses go I was a
very big fan of how this Arc chose to
kick things off and more specifically
how it chose to go about communicating
who gorilla was to us as a character
naturally Exposition can be a
complicated and nuanced Minefield to
navigate and it can be boring cringe or
awkward if you do it the wrong way
however I thought this was superb
firstly by connecting the prior story to
this one in the same chapter the other
story ended it allows us as viewers the
chance to arm ourselves with more
context and anticipation we already know
that 7-3 is valuable and so we don't
need to have that explained to us why he
might be a target for granola
furthermore if you revisit this section
of the story you might be amazed to
notice just how little talking there is
between the end of chapter 67 and the
beginning of the next there's a battle
demonstrating what granola can do what
his objective is and how he goes about
it it shows us his relationship with his
AI how oatmeal is genuinely more more
than just a robot but an entity that
cares for granola's safety and most
vitally to this story it depicts a short
but Illuminating flashback from the
point of view of someone we believe to
be granola towering from an invading
destructive force the Saiyans the vast
majority of this is conveyed to us
without words and it's a delight to
revisit offering alongside this terrific
Pace in the chance for the more
eagle-eyed amongst you to notice a very
specific scarring on this ozaru's left
cheek already I'm hooked and have so
many questions this is exactly how you
would want an arc titled the granola Arc
to commence fueling our engagement with
the story's plot with nostalgic imagery
and connecting us specifically with its
titular character it's a terrific
opening and the First Act hasn't even
begun to show us how brilliant it is yet
because oh boy we got a continuation of
Vegeta and Goku's emotional Journeys in
this Arc one of my many praisings of the
moral are concerned its dedication to
progressing Vegeta's story in meaningful
fashion beyond what had already been
explored once in Dragon Ball Z and
rehashed once again in Dragon Ball super
I've made it clear in the past my
disdain for the vapid repurposing of
already resolved plot lines for the sake
of fake tension whether it be Vegeta's
sudden regression in Battle of Gods from
the way that he was in the Buu saga his
reluctance to work together with Goku
during the Goku black Arc despite the
horrific circumstances or the revisiting
of a popular set piece in a much less
engaging way during the universe
survival Arc Allah Vegeta's sacrifice
however what Moro started with Vegeta's
admission of guilt concerning his past
transgressions on Namek and what granola
continues concerning both Goku and
Vegeta's Journeys has been by far the
most engaging part of the modern Dragon
Ball story for me but I'm dancing around
this a little bit what exactly is done
for both of these characters in this Arc
well a concept this Arc plays with in
its beginning is that of taking both
Goku and Vegeta down two separate paths
to power so to speak one where whis
continues Goku's training and one where
beerus decides to help Vegeta secure his
own means of power and this is explored
and presented in a host of different but
interesting ways one of my favorites is
how the manga visually demonstrates this
idea it's as wonderful as it is subtly
executed I pointed this out on my
Twitter actually not Mark when it was
first released but if you pay attention
to the speech bubbles toyotara uses in
this chapter chapter 68 as well as the
direction of the story you can actually
predict what might happen you can see
the similarities Goku shares with whis
through their shared more rounded and
soft speech bubbles and the more harsh
and angular speech boxes shared by
Vegeta and beerus highlighting in one
breath that Vegeta would be ill-served
as a student of whis sort of like trying
to fit a square block into a circular
hole if you will and that he perhaps
seems to be more aligned with what
beerus has found success with
destruction also there's a moment during
whis's training in chapter 68 I'd love
to draw your attention to it's the first
scene Goku and Vegeta share in the arc
and in it we says something rather
interesting while training Goku's Ultra
Instinct he says copying me won't get
you fire you must develop your own style
the ability to use ultra instinct is not
in and of itself your ultimate goal I
particularly love this lesson for Goku
throughout Dragon Ball his aptitude for
tutelage and mimicking Maneuvers has
been a Cornerstone of his own physical
development and progression he's always
been great at that and to see it used
here as an obstacle for him to overcome
was honestly refreshing this Arc
explores what specifically are the
differences between Goku and Vegeta
highlights their strengths and
weaknesses pushes them in opposite
directions and in the process unites
them by having them embrace the good
about who they are as members of the
same species expressing the lesson that
our histories don't Define and shouldn't
Define who we are only we have the power
to Define our destiny and that's sort of
what granola's Arc in this story is it's
about letting go of the hatred he has in
the past in order to learn how to
embrace what he has now to look forward
to the future but I am getting a little
ahead of myself here so let's talk about
the villains of this Arc the heaters the
main antagonistic force and villain
faction of the Ark are the individuals
known as the heaters as the direct
opposition that rose up in the vacuum
following frieza's demise I like that
the word used to describe them is that
of the heaters a direct opposite to
Frieza both literally and figuratively
which is reflected in their philosophy
where Frieza wanted to squash the
insects directly before him the heaters
are a much more passive Force operating
with and utilizing Intel and money to
crush what stands before them indirectly
so instead of confronting the problem
here head-on that's emerging with
granola growing incredibly strong
instead elek the leader proposes a plan
by which he wants to get Frieza to kill
granola for them which ultimately
doesn't end up too well but that's
skipping to the end now I think this is
one of the less appreciated ideas that
came out of this Arc how the heaters or
more specifically elec is the inverse of
Frieza in many respects during the Namek
Saga because of frieza's immense
pressure and will Vegeta Island Gohan
and even Goku to some extent were forced
to strategize and navigate the tough
ecosystem that was the race for the
dragon balls on Namek at that time it's
one of my favorite parts of that story
for that very reason however with
regards to the heaters in this Arc
instead of the gang being required to
carefully navigate their way around Alex
attention he uses his anonymity to his
own Advantage choosing instead of
contending with them themselves he
instead implements strategies of his own
by pushing and manipulating others to
confront each other succeeding in doing
so with granola only because of his Lust
For Revenge blinding him to what's truly
going on with oatmeal being the only
voice of reason here to help guide the
Bounty Hunter the symbolism of oatmeal
being a mechanical eye that's trying to
help granola see his own situation for
what it is being a nice touch I think
furthermore there's a great quote from
Alec during Chapter 70 that illuminates
for us exactly the sort of person he is
when asked if he was considering
granola's request for info and Frieza he
said he wouldn't tell him where he is is
because and I quote if granola takes
Frieza out he'll just take his place as
the next big boss and that Throne
belongs to us the heaters I like this
comment from the leader of the heater's
Alec because it shares information about
the plot while also telling us some
vitally important and almost prophetic
information about elec and where his
weaknesses ultimately lie he's never
going to be the sort of person who would
trust anyone or do anything for anyone
other than himself it's his belief that
everyone is as selfish as he is which
explains why he acts and makes decisions
the way he does both now at the
beginning of this Arc and tragically at
the very end with the chapter
culminating on a foreboding vision from
the Oracle fish predicting that the
strongest in the universe will soon rise
up is it a misleading or direct prophecy
who knows but the pieces are most
definitely falling into place for this
Arc to work right now however the best
part of this chapter chapter 69 comes
shortly after and it's very easy to miss
if you're not paying attention in fact
it takes place between two pages
specifically these two pages eight and
nine I'm sure many of you watching
understand what a transition is
oftentimes it's a standard method of
cutting from one scene to another
however to some authors or directors it
can be a useful mechanism to do exactly
that while also communicating something
more narratively granola as he's walking
back to his home to greet monaito is
seen looking down at his ruined one-time
home it communicates not only a desire
for Revenge that granola has but also
something that keeps his focus on what
was rather than what could be still
holding on to the Past despite the pain
it causes him but where's the transition
you might be asking well we get a series
of shots depicting granola's memory of
the event with uzaro's destroying the
world left and right creating the
perfect opportunity to switch to a
Saiyan talking about his past still
haunted by the guilt of those very
events his people took part in and
wrought on the universe while the visual
transition from uzaro to Vegeta is
obvious but it's also the psychological
similarities that these two pages and
characters Vegeta and granola share side
by side that's alluded to here another
aspect I love about this Arc is the
level of care that's gone into the
interpersonal interactions between
beasts and Goku in contrast with beerus
and Vegeta I mentioned the differences
in temperament which was highlighted
through the speech bubbles however it
extends beyond that and all the way to
the means with which they teach and how
they fight one another whis calmly
conveying his philosophy to Goku
encouraging him to embrace his own style
and follow his own path to alter
Instinct Mastery focusing entirely on
Dodges and invasive Maneuvers all the
wild beerus bluntly tells Vegeta exactly
what his problems are grinds his face
into the dust and antagonizes him
relentlessly with quips about how he was
the one who gave Frieza the order to
blow up planet Vegeta I love stuff like
this it gives each encounter its very
own flavor without sacrificing the
entertainment factor which intentionally
represents what toyotaro and Toriyama
want for these characters for them to no
longer directly Chase to one another
with one always being left out in the
dust but to instead explore their
differences and find New Paths to their
respective destinations that way with
beerus's final emphatic philosophical
message to Vegeta found through a phrase
he's used before in this series before
creation comes destruction in order for
Vegeta to achieve what he desires in
this instance the power of a destroyer
he must recreate himself from scratch
free from the guilty shackles he
self-imposes unto himself due to his and
his races past now this isn't to say
however that this Arc doesn't have some
lazy instances of writing either though
while the interpersonal Journey's
obvious characters have been given a lot
of consideration there are sometimes
pivotal pieces of exposition which get
dropped at the most convenient of times
without which the plot simply couldn't
work which I honestly think is a problem
one of the reasons I like the
progression of the story is explored
through Goku Vegeta and granola in this
Arc largely has to do with them being
natural continuations of their existing
character's history why did I like the
connective tissue between between the
Last Arc and this one well because the
story flowed naturally 7-3 was kidnapped
granola stolen which makes sense gave
him to the heaters for payment which
makes sense and through 7-3 the heaters
learned about the Dragon Balls thus
setting up one side of the conflict in
the story that's great and it makes
logical sense there's a natural line of
cause and effect one could easily follow
and believe however the same does not
occur with granola's storyline
unfortunately in one small instance we
learned that Manita was holding on to
one of the two dragon balls on that
world and so granola has no means of
searching for it without a great deal of
effort until moments later he hears a
news report saying that someone found it
right after Minato told him not to go
looking for it like okay what are the
odds that the very moment he needs it it
appears before him ready to steal now I
can appreciate that they didn't want to
spend a lot of time locating the ball
and all that kind of stuff and just get
to the wish part but then come up with a
different way of achieving this doing
stuff like this I will always criticize
it sucks me out of the story and it's a
shame because this one is honestly
better than that following this granola
makes the decision to follow the Path of
Revenge sacrificing his very life force
in the name of achieving the power he
requires to reach his violent goals and
look I'm gonna spoil it here Vegeta and
granola fight each other later in this
Arc now I don't think that's much of a
surprise to anyone or at least it
shouldn't be first of all you should
have read the ark before watching this
review I mean that's kind of the point
but it should also be obvious
narratively while in the previous
chapter their similarities were
highlighted Chapter 70 focuses on their
differences with Vegeta demonstrating
his struggle to achieve this new
technique which will grant him the
ability to achieve his goal highlighted
as he fails to destroy the rock on his
hand but does later succeed in
destroying a tiny Pebble on his finger
showing us as viewers that he is willing
to patiently apply himself to achieve
this goal finding the process itself
fulfilling whereas granola a few pages
later blows up a massive Boulder with
ease following His Wish pleased with the
results but still unfulfilled looking to
enact his revenge and after getting
Intel from zuno Maki and oiled the other
haters leveraged Goku and Vegeta's
weakness their wives which honestly is
kind of hilarious to make contact with
them and ultimately to deliver them to
granola granola is made aware of what's
going on and eagerly accepts the mission
he's given knowing it will bring him
closer to the Revenge he desires all the
characters here have received the proper
setup for their respective arcs in the
story and in addition to that have
accepted their calls to action Goku and
Vegeta are going to investigate a
supposed villain in a distant world and
granola is going to confront the people
that he blames for destroying his world
this concludes the introductory portion
of the First Act of the story and
overall as an introductory portion or
First Act of the story this is a
brilliant near perfect release from
toyotaro one that establishes the themes
of the arc the general direction of the
course of the characters and most
importantly I think makes full use of
the 45 pages a monthly release of Fords
I've argued the pros of a weekly release
in the past are a bi-weekly release but
in this instance it's a terrific benefit
to the story given that there was so
much to communicate in these chapters
can they keep it up well let's see Goku
and Vegeta versus granola this section
is interesting to me because unlike many
other physical engagements these two get
in Goku isn't the star but instead the
supporting character and while he
himself has a journey to undergo in this
story this section in particular is
Vegeta and granolas with Goku's
involvement only really there to
facilitate Vegeta and granola's story so
let's talk about it gorilla seems to
exhibit techniques synonymous with that
of what Goku and Vegeta are specifically
training for making him in one breath
the Thematic inverse of hard work pays
off while additionally being the perfect
individual for them to work together to
overcome however as Vegeta says
following Goku's questioning whether or
not they ought to try working together
he says that's absurd pushing instead
for Goku to try his hand at granola
first already this feels strange because
normally Vegeta is the one eager to get
in first and Goku cleans up his scraps
afterwards however what first seems like
a desire to surpass kakara yet again as
time passes we see glimpses that it
might be a little more complicated than
that with Vegeta unlike granola which is
important thinking about this situation
critically not convinced the
circumstances are as simple as they've
been told they were wishing to keep his
eyes peeled for more information as Goku
confronts granola directly now Goku vs
granola has some nice paneling here and
there with Pages 15 and 16 on chapter 73
being some standout favorites of mine
narratively this chapter is quite light
with a large focus on the action element
of the story despite very little
actually being said in the process now
to be clear there is some information to
be understood from this chapter however
when you compare it to the other more
narratively dense chapters we've gotten
moments prior it's easy to see why there
is a population of people who dislike
how Super's manga uses its fights action
is great but we want action that tells
and contributes largely to the story too
not one that prevents or gets in the way
of it and while this one does tell some
story the issue is is that there's not
really enough story in this one chapter
to satiate the appetite of some readers
for an entire month which is a shame
because Toriyama and toyotaro are
clearly capable of delivering plenty of
story as made evident by the other
chapters in this Arc they fight back and
forth as Goku Cycles through Super
Saiyan God Super Saiyan blue and
eventually Ultra Instinct now Goku and
Vegeta do suss out what's going on and
Goku gets taken out by granola now
fighting with a much higher level of
power and while that last chapter was
very light on plot one thing I will say
is that I did very much like the
inclusion of the shigerian's point of
view both in that chapter and this one
chapter 74. terrified that their world
will come crumbling down around them
granola wouldn't have wished any harm on
these people initially but his lack of
consideration for anything outside of
his one goal with his mind so focused so
consumed with revenge in his past it's
clear that he can see the potential
suffering and damage he's causing to
those living in the Here and Now present
day and furthermore this is where the
differences between Vegeta and granola
paid dividends for the Saiyan Prince I
mentioned how Vegeta was content with
slowly seeing progression to bigger and
better things with regards to his own
training and because of this Vegeta is
able to expose granola's naivety in
battle both strategically and physically
he says he'd I repeat myself you may be
stronger but that's no guarantee that
I'll lose to you this is reflected in
whis's tutelage towards Goku earlier in
the arc wherein he mentions that Goku's
failing is in his understanding of ultra
Instinct as a transformation when it's
not at all that but more so an
augmentation of their powers this idea
of experience and ability divorced from
power is something I've been interested
in seeing explored again in Dragon Ball
it's always a treat continuing into
chapter 75 Vegeta begins to demonstrate
his commitment and Embraces the
philosophy beerus laid out before him by
saying a God of destruction told me that
power derives solely from instinct is
unbounded this notion that accepting who
you are and embracing what makes Vegeta
who he is doesn't have to be something
one should feel guilty about we are who
we are regardless of what we've done and
certainly regardless of what our parents
and race have done collectively and
what's really important is what we
choose to do with that power or ability
and so by embracing his body's natural
aptitude for fighting in combat in
conjunction with his newly acquired God
of destruction abilities it leads to
this chaotic force that surges in power
the more he experiences battle and I
think that's a really cool idea for
Vegeta with this very idea of
self-actualization demonstrated in
chapter 75 too by Vegeta saying and I
quote I am the master of my own fate
this is a statement that Echoes
throughout the themes of this fight
between granola and Vegeta with Vegeta
himself using this philosophy to reach
granola because he sees so much of
himself in him I mentioned earlier that
one of my pet peeves for the Dragon Ball
super anime was its consistent
application or rehashing perhaps is a
better word of Prior successful story
beats for the sake of gathering fake
tension we saw it with the likes of
Piccolo sacrificing himself to save
Gohan we saw it with Vegeta replicating
his sacrifice during the tournament of
power you get the picture however I
think in chapter 75 there's perhaps the
most appropriate callback to an older
scene that's ever been implemented in
modern Dragon Ball I might be mistaken
but I think this could very well be the
case and it takes place on pages 36 and
37 of chapter 75. in it we see Vegeta
perplexed seeing granola standing he
says curse him still standing and ready
to fight I'll have to end this now
This Will Destroy anything it touches
want to protect your
job you better stop this yourself now
does this remind anyone watching of any
other scene in this series how about
Vegeta's very first fight in all of
Dragon Ball against Goku and the Cena I
thought this was a really cool idea it's
evident through later conversations
between granola and Vegeta that Vegeta
himself is willing and trying on some
level to reach granola and the fashion
with which toyotaro demonstrates this is
great there are numerous points in this
battle where granola starts to destroy
things that are important to him from
some stray shots to his ruined home to
full on destroying the area himself the
chaos he's bringing to the shigerians
that currently reside on this planet and
of course the sudden realization that he
himself is being seen as the monster
he's trying to supposedly get Justice
against in the context of Dragon Ball Z
Vegeta is shouting these statements to
Goku not to draw anything out of him but
to only boast and try to destroy the
Earth in recreating this moment in this
scene it intentionally tries to place
our minds back to that headspace however
as this conflict between Vegeta and
granola comes to an end with the
utilization of this scene highlighting
and contrasting for me the Stark
differences that exist between who
Vegeta was during his battle with Goku
on Earth and who he is now someone who
will actively take the time to try to
explain to an enemy that's trying to
kill him what he feels like he needs to
know for Vegeta has once been consumed
by hatred and revenge and more than
anyone else knows the path that leads
down it's wonderfully handled and the
structure of this Arc I think works very
well the Bardock flashback storyline
which occurs right about now and
continues to appear thereafter serves as
both the lessons and closure the ark's
emotional threads require as such it is
drip fed throughout the present day
series of events and fights that take
place right up until well the climax it
works extremely well for a story in
terms of structure but not so well for
review jumping back and forth between
two different points in time and scenes
only will get confusing quickly and
would really only work if I was looking
to recap the store and I have no
interest of doing that so I absolutely
intend and talk about Bardock a little
later on but for the sake of brevity
let's chat about the events that make up
the first conflict in this Arc between
the heroes and villains of this story
gas versus the heroes round one there's
a lot of fighting in this Arc but
honestly a lot less than I would have
thought or remembered a criticism I felt
from one side of the aisle when I was
working up to review this story was that
there was too much fighting and while I
feel like that wasn't the case during my
binge of the material I think I know
where that sentiment might be coming
from unlike the Last Arc which had so
many more individual fights this Arc has
three main conflicts the first we have
already touched on between the main
three Heroes of this Arc however thanks
to some Illuminating information from
Minato Vegeta and Goku bernola has
discovered the truth behind the futility
of his initial revenge and as such
switches gears to help Goku and Vegeta
against gas this is the second fight
with the third and final fight coming
shortly after a brief reprieve from the
fight to learn more about himself and
Goku's father all of these fights
contribute in some small way to the
themes and story of the Ark however the
issue I think some people see is that
the fighting while it has some substance
it's not enough to justify a month-long
wait between chapters pretty pictures
and cool action is enough for a lot of
people but waiting a month for what
amounts to little story progression I
can well imagine is frustrating for
others this is why I singled out and
praised the first four or five chapters
for being so dense and earning that
monthly release I think monthly releases
can work you just need to release an
adequate amount of story progression to
justify it keeping that in mind however
the fights do get to expose a few
interesting elements that this Arc plays
with progression through struggle is
another of dragon Ball's core tenants
that's reinforced during this story not
just with the obvious Goku and Vegeta
contenders but through the likes of
granola as made obvious by his quick
progression into unlocking his Race's
secret second red eye through combat
despite already wishing to be the
strongest however it's what we get with
gas that's interesting in response to
Alex saying he'll make his wish for gas
gas says I'm fine as I am suggesting
that he doesn't need a power-up from the
Dragon Balls coach I'm me
why would I want to be anything else
I'm not sure you realize how
psychologically healthy that actually is
this is the inverse of Goku and Vegeta's
philosophy while gas doesn't seem to
need to learn it elec is forcing this
regression onto him until finally he
forces gas to release his inner nature
losing all control and becoming a hulky
monster for a time before eventually
regaining his sense of self honestly the
heaters and more specifically elec here
is a very refreshing and interesting
counter philosophy to everything the
Hero characters are trying to learn here
where they are doing everything
themselves due to that yielding the best
self-improvement outcome elec
consistently looks for others to do his
Dirty Work where they each show one
another the true value of hard work and
the value of the journey itself he's all
about the results forcing his own
brother to do things he otherwise
doesn't want to do and okay this section
is wild with the beginning of chapter 81
being especially brutal to say the least
Goku and Vegeta face to the floor
granola for his troubles receives two
broken arms his eyes gashed and a torso
shot through gonna need a sensu for that
one some of this is difficult to look at
and additionally there's a great
sequence where Goku flexes his use and
experience with instant transmission
thanks in part to an unrequested power
boost from Vegeta leading Goku and we
used to have this specific conversation
when asked how his training has been
going Goku responds honestly I'm still
having a lot of trouble with it I just
can't keep my heart cam the way you do
this to which he responds well that's
understandable as an angel I'm a
fundamentally different life form than
you oh foreshadowing following this Goku
has given his father's old scouter by
Minato and contained within it is an
audio log and what's a nice touch is
that as soon as this audio log orders a
word or phrase that resonates with Goku
it reminds him of a long lost memory
it's a beautiful moment for the
character and one that is unique in the
franchise and I think what is
interesting about this is that Goku
isn't necessarily resistant to the idea
of embracing his Saiyan Heritage or
personhood there aren't too many
instances in the series where Goku has
been confronted by his past you've got
his brother a few conversations with
Vegeta and maybe Frieza that's it really
this is the
involvement Goku has had with his past
and that in and of itself I think is
interesting interesting because he's
never struck me as a character that
actively hid away from his Saiyan
lineage his conversations with Raditz
and Vegeta concerning the subject felt
more like he was alluding to their
morality as individuals rather than
their race specifically being dubious
and these are conversations that
occurred right at the beginning of Z so
we're talking about subject matter Rudy
which has had seeds planted for well
over 30 years it's captivating
I want to say from the outset that the
fact this story is confined entirely
within the memories of Goku granola
monaito and a single scouter is not only
a cool idea but also a surprisingly
resonant one and it's a tale that serves
this story perfectly well I think it
delivers some interesting action
wonderful lessons for Goku and granola
and is delivered in the story in a host
of creative ways with none quite as
engaging to me as the moment Paradox
scouter is handed to his only surviving
Son Goku it held my attention and
honestly gripped me as a fan of the
series with it triggering one of Goku's
only memories of his father and grants
us a sneak peek into what will more than
likely be a pivotal moment for that
iconic character moving forward earlier
in the year I made a video dedicated to
the issues or should I say the potential
implications this story might have for
the greater Dragon Ball story and my
concerns with regards to that are
largely unchanged as an older dragon
ball fan when I was growing up I perhaps
wrongly had a preconceived notion as to
what I thought Goku's backstory was with
non-canon tv specials coloring my mind
for cert however my issue and I think
many folks's issues with the new Bardock
story is more so how derivative it feels
to that of the Superman story which to
us felt a lot less interesting compared
to what we had been suggested in the
past by admittedly non-canon material
with that said I'm happy to move past
that and accept Bardock and Goku's newly
revealed origin from what it is it is
after all Akira Toriyama story and he
has every right to do with it what he
pleases it's his Series so what happens
in these flashbacks well there are a
host of flashbacks to the same pivotal
event in granola's childhood the day the
Saiyans invaded to destroy his home The
Fallout following these flashbacks each
one granting more and more information
that broadens the scope and implications
of the plot I think serve the Thematic
Resonance of the story really well
although I do have one significant
pickup which one it still has the
potential of being explained away later
hasn't as of right now and due to that
runs the risk of flying in the face of
one of the story's themes with that said
I think it sets up potential new stories
for the coming arcs to exploring good
detail and I think it's genuinely
heartwarming and great to see Goku
finally learn something about his past
all of that honestly I think is terrific
and with regards to bardock's
involvement in this Arc while there's an
aspect to it I didn't like I will say
that there is more than one layer to it
to appreciate with each layer offering
something to enjoy so let's explore the
other layers before getting to my
concern player one the most obvious and
surface level observations I can make
regarding this are all positive it's a
refreshing reprieve from the typical
Fair we've grown accustomed to with
regards to Dragon Ball getting to see
barluck and the Saiyans in their Heyday
is such an interesting and rare
occurrence to the story so getting to
see uzarus and Sans running amok is a
satisfying and awesome sight to see the
second Lair having spent a number of
years now reviewing other popular series
it's very interesting now for me to
return to class Dragon Ball to notice
that flashbacks were used extremely
seldomly so infrequently in fact that I
can only really think of one example off
the top of my head right now and that
was the time Frieza thought of Bardock
when he saw Goku for the first time and
that didn't even make proper use of all
the options of flashback in a story can
offer this Arc in super however does
utilize them and the benefits of doing
so are explored in the third layer this
is the layer where I think most people
place a large amount of their focus and
I honestly can't blame them this is by
far the most important layer for you to
get the most out of the story and offers
most of the narrative fun for example it
offers the heaters another chance to
demonstrate how conniving opportunistic
and ruthless they truly are emphasized
brilliantly through a page turn from 37
to 38 in chapter 77 Bardock trying to
buy him an Ito muesli and granola's
lives a chance once his proposal is
complete boom Alex shoots granola's mom
without hesitation and that's not even
to draw attention to the subtle hints to
the dynamic gas shares with his older
brother elec furthermore and with the
main cast since the beginning of this
Arc we've only really seen glimpses into
this invasion of paradox however thanks
to the scouter provided by the late
Bardock himself Goku and granola now
have a person to thank for helping them
continue to fight in one light we have
granola learning the truth of who or
what the Saiyans are something not to
fear or hate necessarily as made evident
by Bardock and now Goku and Vegeta who
have saved him time and again this is in
line with the themes of the arc itself
and we get Goku's inspiration for how he
will eventually overcome his mental
block with ultra instinct to some extent
again all wonderful creative choices
that I love in this story and heck
there's a specific scene that addresses
this issue of Vegeta granola and Goku's
with pages 31-34 on chapter 83 showing a
younger gas ask Bardock if he's either
fighting out of guilt to atone for his
racist sins or perhaps out of Revenge
unsurprisingly these are the motivations
that once fueled both Vegeta and gorilla
to which Paradox answer actually reveals
the lesson Goku needs to learn it's a
brilliant scene and one that succinctly
end answers the issues all of these
protagonists have resulting in perhaps
the best page turn toyotaro has ever
drawn and that has been pinned in Dragon
Ball Super's manga run in my opinion it
is utterly spectacular with Goku and
Vegeta Having learned what they needed
to from this journey now standing in
front of gas the strongest of the
heaters ready to put their Newfound
powers to the test as a team against
this great threat it's very satisfying
no longer trying to be something they're
not or stuck in the past both are now
embracing who they are and living in the
moment and Thrill of the fight gas
versus the heroes round two
here we are at the third and final fight
of the arc well sort of and the
choreography of this encounter is really
fun boasting some really nice clean
paneling as well as some team-up moves
between the two Saiyans we rarely ever
see something I really enjoyed about
this fight is made clear in chapter 85.
Vegeta after making the exact
take on gas alone erupts with joy when
he gets attacked and takes damage
because as he says his alter ego form
continues to evolve but quips to Goku
that his Ultra instinct is the same as
it has always been and orders that while
he Vegeta keeps gas busy Goku figure out
his problem in doing this this scene
alone combines the strengths of two of
my favorite Vegeta scenes one being the
confrontation with Android 19 where
Vegeta continues to surpass the wildest
parameters of the Android's database and
Vegeta of course versus Kid Buu where he
shows just how incredible and tenacious
he is fighting a much stronger opponent
alone to buy time for Goku only
difference being this fight has more
tension and respect put on Vegeta's name
than the Boo and Android fights offered
with the solution that Goku ultimately
comes to being rather satisfying it's
not another transformation it's not
another technique but instead a shifting
in perspective no longer fighting
against his true nature to remain calm
and unexcited in a fight but instead
embracing that aspect of of him through
the utilization of a previously known
facade and this fight is honestly
Bonkers with Goku whipping out
everything from old faithfuls to move
seldom scene in the series with the
fight excelling to new heights once elec
pushes gas over the edge to burn away
his youth for the sake of Power with his
other brothers pointing out that gas
ain't looking too hot right now and is
looking pretty ancient to which elec
responds not to worry his power is very
much intact as if that was the only
thing worthy of consideration and for me
the paneling for this fight was honestly
the strongest between chapters 85 and
86. there are some truly great layouts
here that make use of the width and the
height of the page but to bring it back
to the point I like this fight and think
is appropriate because it shows Goku and
Vegeta fighting the physical embodiment
of all their struggles they've had to
overcome on this journey in the ark and
right before our eyes and theirs we see
exactly where that sort of toxic
thinking leads you and just as this
battle Roars onward with gas singing the
upsides of this Choice gorilla makes the
save on Goku and this is where the
conclusion becomes the best ending to a
fight Dragon Ball super has delivered in
my opinion not just because I'm a fan of
the story for all of the reasons I've
mentioned but it also manages to make
use of every single member of the hero
team weak or not without exception to
create the scenario that made for one
heck of a finish granola charges his
finishing attack while Goku defends and
distracts however eventually Goku is
beaten down about to be destroyed Vegeta
throws his body against gas for another
last-ditch effort to draw his attention
away despite Vegeta himself having no
energy at all all the while oil and Maki
are put to sleep by Minato before they
can intervene and just as granola is
about to fire about to finish his charge
Goku's hidden power awakens once again
like he did in the moro Arc to position
gas away from the earth a safe Target
now presents itself and this this is my
favorite part granola's eye eyes are
still suffering from the effects of the
last battle and can't aim correctly
creating the perfect opportunity for
oatmeal the little loyal AI to chime in
and offer his aiming assist Services
culminating in one spectacular final
attack from granola the perfect person
to fire this final blast it's a
breathtaking finish to what has
ultimately been a near brilliantly
structured Arc however with that said I
still want to talk about one other
aspect of it and it revolves around the
implications of bardock's wish made on
the dragon Ball's courtesy of Minato the
wish Bardock makes in chapter 83 speaks
perhaps to a theme echoed in this Arc
one where you shouldn't have your
attention focused on the past where you
shouldn't wish your life away for the
sake of Revenge but to instead cherish
the possibilities the future holes to
cherish what exists now it's a beautiful
sentiment and one that is felt
throughout this Arc to varying degrees
that affects a host of other characters
however my issue with it is divorce from
the Thematic significance which it
definitely has and more so pertains to
the potential implications it might have
for the rest of the series narratively I
spoke about it in an older video closer
to when these chapters came out but the
wording of Braddock's wish whether it be
vis's translation saying he wishes his
children Thrive or whether it be other
accurate translations suggesting he
wished his children to grow up healthy
both run the risk of implying that Goku
didn't survive his childhood years in
early Dragon Ball due to who he was but
instead the wishes of his father
enforced through magic which robs I
think that section that early section of
the story and impact it had for me at
the very least but I do however have
hope and to be honest it more than
likely will be something that will be
addressed by Akira Toriyama eventually
at some point down the road because if
there's one thing I know about Akira
toriyama's writing is that he loves to
keep things vague intentionally Goku
being an alien didn't contradict much of
anything in the original material
because it was kept vague beerus being
the one to give the order to Frieza
doesn't contradict anything really in
the main Canon because again he kept it
vague there are plenty of instances in
this story where Akira Toriyama wrote
the story in such a loose and vague
fashion because he either didn't know
what to write there and then at the time
or intended on expanding upon it later
either way he kept it vague to not write
himself into a corner within which there
would be no return and while this looks
like it could be a potential issue that
might impact the tension and achievement
of Goku from childhood to adulthood it's
also entirely possible that Akira
Toriyama intended for that wearing to
imply the safe passage of Goku from
planet Vegeta to Earth and that from
that point on he'd be on his own it's
impossible to say at this point as he
has left it very vague despite the fact
that there are a number of panels where
Goku and Vegeta seem to address this
aspect and brush it off as a joke and
look whether you value this concern
people have or not whether you like this
decision more than the consequences it
may mean for early Dragon Ball I think
it should be safe to suggest that we all
value you different things about this
series and I hope I communicated those
worries here today well enough for those
that don't agree to potentially
understand and empathize with it to a
certain extent but to close it off I
think we
think was this Arc makes is by
displaying gas as an otherwise very
sympathetic character one whose only
motivation is to do his brother proud
and to not let his family down to prove
himself his worth all the while Alec
isn't concerned with that and whom gas
trusts is willing to slowly watch his
brother Decay away he's despicable I
mean all does is hide behind people at
least Frieza does things first
Frieza is back in the mix baby and I
love him so so much it hurts my body he
gets some quippy lines perfect for his
character he looks terrifying enormously
more powerful thanks to some secret
training in another world or Dimension
making him perhaps now the strongest in
this Dimension and the best part is that
this was sort of foreshadowed in some
respect in chapter 82 where the Oracle
fish after seeing gas doesn't recognize
and peace looks confused at this
Revelation suggesting that he wasn't the
one the fish had visions of suggesting
that he alone wasn't the strongest in
the universe that frees on this and then
Frieza just pieces out leaving everyone
shocked it's perfect I can't wait to see
where Akira Toriyama and toriotaro go
with this uh yeah if you enjoyed this
video be sure to leave a like And
subscribe for more like this but until
then I've been totally not Mark I'll see
you all next weekend thank you so much
for watching it feels good to be back
reviewing Dragon Ball
thank you